dont jean-marc pourquoi est ce si
difficile de se mettre d'accord à 27
c'est difficile tout simplement parce
que l'europe n'est pas un état c'est une
union de pays qui ont mis en commun ça
peut donc deux choses mais dont les
solidarités reste fondé sur le
volontarisme alors c'est un peu comme
dans une grande famille d'accord quand
tout va bien ça marche quand tout va mal
ça craque et la crise du coronavirus a
révélé la fragilité de certains pays
leur incapacité à s'organiser l'italie
l'espagne
d'autres s'en sortent plutôt mieux donc
c'est très difficile d'organiser une
solidarité ce qui s'est passé ce
week-end c'est très banal
finalement vous avez dans l'union
européenne vous le disiez une série de
pays qui sont assez riches et qui refuse
de payer pour les plus pauvres c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça le sommet avait
l'ambition ce sommet qui avait été
initié un président et par qui et qui
est présidée par angela merkel avec
emmanuel macron 3 ambitions
la première c'était dégager 750
milliards d'euros pour répondre à la
crise 500 milliards sous forme de
subventions et des aides aux pays qui
sont en difficulté et 250 milliards sous
forme de prêts
la deuxième ambition c'était pour
financer tout ça de lancer un emprunt
garanti par l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne et c'est la première
fois que l'allemagne accepté de
mutualiser cette date c'était quand même
un événement est un tournant historique
et puis la troisième édition basse était
de répartir cet argent plutôt au profit
des pays très blessé des pays qui en ont
besoin comme l'espagne ou l'italie en
gros les pays de l'europe du sud la
discussion a révélé que certains la
suède la finlande les pays-bas
l'autriche n'était pas favorable à cette
clé de répartition qui favorise les pays
du sud en clair il voulait pas payer
pour ces pays qui sont 10 est il mauvais
gestionnaires qui ont fait des dettes et
qui font pas les réformes qu'il faudrait
faire pour pouvoir se tenir correctement
et alors comment est ce qu'on s'en sort
les discussions reprennent cet après
midi oui alors les discussions vont
reprendre dans l'après midi vers 16h
mais en bas sans doute discuter sur la
répartition des sommes qui sont alloués
se forme de tête de près et des sommes
qui sont allouées sous forme d' aide ou
subvention
initialement on devait répartir les 750
milliards en 500 milliards d'un côté
sous forme d'aile et de subventions et
puis 250 milliards sous forme de prêts
qui aurait dû être
remboursés automatiquement les pays
frugaux comme on les appelle c'est à
dire en gros certains disent même qu'ils
sont radins voudrait augmenter la part
octroyé sous forme de dettes dont
remboursables et diminuer la part due
forme dit on en réalité ils savent très
bien que les dettes que feront les
espagnols les italiens ou les grecs ne
seront pas remboursés ou ont du mal à
être remboursés donc ils font comme si
ils seront remboursés
c'est enfin le championnat d'europe de
livres et mais ce qui est nouveau quand
même dans ce qui se passa à bruxelles
c'est que la france et l'allemagne
marche n'est même pas c'est vrai en gala
merkel bénéficie d'une très grosse cote
dans son pays et elle a voulu faire
passer l'idée que l'allemagne avait
besoin de l'europe pour vendre ses
produits pour vendre notamment ses
voitures 1 et pour exister au niveau
international elle a besoin d'une europe
forte d'où son souci d'aider les plus
malades donc elle a réussi à convaincre
son opinion publique
il fallait marcher sur le chemin de la
solidarité l'allemagne a besoin des pays
du sud mais elle voudrait expliqué aussi
que les hollandais les suédois ont
besoin de l'europe du sud et pas
seulement pour venir en vacances pas
seulement pour venir profiter des plages
du midi de de la région espagnole ou de
l'italie tous ces pays ont déjà beaucoup
investi en plus en espagne en italie en
grèce
donc ils voudraient que leurs
investissements ne s'effondre pas donc
vous voyez ils ont quand même intérêt à
ce que l'europe du sud fonctionne et
c'est sur ce deal là que je pense que le
compromis va se faire je crois pour
réduire à légèrement la part des aides
et des subventions au profit ont fait un
petit peu la tête remboursables mais on
doit pouvoir s'en sortir parce que si
l'europe ne s'en sort pas elle risque de
s'effondrer avec des effets systémiques
qui seront généralisées merci jean marc
sylvestre pour toutes ces précisions